on this saturday night
the devastating peak of the third wave
icu admissions hit a record high in
ontario
with more patience on ventilators people
think they're invincible
and they can't get it but i'm sorry to
say you can
as the virus fixates on younger people
the rollout of the johnson
johnson vaccine on hold in canada the
worsening wave
in india and these two weeks are going
to be a hell for us
american aid is on the way to this
desperate nation
and the long run i'm going to attempt to
run
30 marathons in 30 days a bc woman's
marathon mission
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us for doctors in canada's biggest
province
their biggest fears have come true
ontario has now set
a new record for the number of patients
with cova 19
in intensive care 900 people are in the
icu
and many of them are on ventilators but
just as worrisome is the new face of
this new wave
a younger demographic michael couture
has our top story tonight
if i can get it anyone can get it people
think they're invincible
and they can't get it but i'm sorry to
say you can
a dire warning from a 30 year old retail
worker hospitalized with covid19
in many ways danica pedipa is the face
of canada's third wave
the dartmouth nova scotia woman has
spent nearly a week in hospital so far
it was scary because i didn't know you
know was like
was i going to come home you know was i
ever going to see my husband again
we're going to see my animals again i
didn't know
remarkably her husband is doing fine
petty paw doesn't know where she
contracted the virus
and is warning others to take kovid 19
seriously
it comes as nova scotia reported a
record 148
new cases saturday that's the highest
number of daily cases since the pandemic
began
but it's not unexpected the province is
dealing with a lab
backlog covid 19 case counts are also
high in alberta
as that province continues to have the
largest average number of confirmed
cases
per 100 thousand people in ontario
intensive care units have hit
a new milestone with 900 patients in
critical care
putting an even greater strain on the
provincial health care system
what that's doing is essentially
cannibalizing most of the things
in hospitals at the moment our backlog
of surgeries
is about a quarter million cases
compared to where we were this time last
year
doctors on the front lines are feeling
the stress but there is
also a sense of optimism if we look at
the whole picture we are
already starting to see a plateauing of
the hospitalizations
the community numbers and even the icu
numbers so we're probably
close to the crest and then things will
start to get better in the next couple
of weeks
but clearly some people don't think we
should wait that long
an anti-lockdown protest in montreal
forced the city's largest vaccination
center
to close saturday i think it's not fair
what they're doing
summer is coming back we want to free
them back we need our summer
politicians and health officials say the
sooner people follow the rules
the sooner things can go back to normal
demonstrations like this one
may only prolong the lockdowns michael
couture global news
ottawa canada's vaccination campaign
is facing another setback health canada
is putting a hold on the first shipment
of the johnson johnson vaccine
three hundred thousand doses of the
one-shot vaccine arrived in the country
on wednesday
but the shipment came from the baltimore
maryland plant that mixed ingredients
ruining 15 million doses health canada
tells global news it is completing an
assessment
before releasing the vaccines for
distribution
the copen 19 crisis in canada's
long-term care homes has taken the lives
of more than 15 000 canadians
now an independent report looking into
the sector in ontario
shows chronic underfunding and severe
staffing shortages
contributed to the deaths of the most
vulnerable during the first wave of the
pandemic
and while that was happening medical
experts warned that
infection prevention programs needed an
overhaul
before the second wave hit as emmanuella
campanella reports
those warnings were not heated
as the pandemic started to claim its
first victims
it was clear long-term care residents
were the most vulnerable
then coven 19 became a shock wave that
cracked wide all the fractures in our
long-term care home system
including the lack of infection
prevention and control measures
known as ipac which are essential for
managing
outbreaks and while ontario had months
to prepare
after the catastrophic first wave those
on the front line say
care homes were ill-equipped for the
second why
was this sector so neglected and why
did nobody act on what was learned in
the first wave to prevent it from
happening in the second wave
global news obtained documents that show
ipac leaders across toronto were calling
for stronger infection prevention and
control measures
everyone recognized just how
bad things were and how much was needed
in the spring
the team of physicians was asking for a
dedicated hospital lead
to train nursing home staff on how to
prevent transmission
and the proper use of personal
protective equipment
you know people who work in long-term
care are not trained to do infection
prevention and control the same way as
people who work in hospitals
an internal document obtained through
freedom of information reveals
the ontario government knew ipac was
significantly under-resourced
to protect basic needs of residents it
wasn't until the late fall
when the second wave was in full force
that the provincial government gave care
homes details of their ipac plan
they would get some support from
hospitals but they were still left to
run their own program
the ministry of long-term care says it
identified at-risk homes
and also provided ipac support through
training modules and staffing from the
red cross
still health experts say ipac needs to
be prioritized
for the long term you're trying to put
out fires as opposed to trying to
prevent the fires
what we really need to do is to start to
try to get ahead of it instead of
managing a crisis start working on
preventing
the next crisis emanuela campanella
global news toronto
to learn more about our investigation
into how long-term care homes were ill
prepared for the second wave
watch the new reality tonight at 7 here
on global
the european union wants to salvage its
tourism industry by implementing
vaccine passports these digital green
certificates would provide proof of a
vaccine against copa 19
recovery from the illness or a negative
test result
the eu still has to figure out a uniform
plan among its own member states
but if international travel is going to
happen the canadian government will have
to consider its own program
here's our chief political correspondent
david aiken
to cross an international border you
will almost certainly need a passport
but now some countries are thinking of
also asking travelers
to produce a cova-19 vaccination
certificate
a vaccine passport this would be
recognized at borders as proof
that an individual has been vaccinated
but while some other jurisdictions
notably the european union and the
united states
are moving quickly to develop
vaccination certificate systems
canada has only just started work on the
concept
i can assure you that our decisions will
be based on science
and the fact that those decisions are
ongoing and those discussions are
ongoing right now
means that we will be aligned with our
partners around the world
one problem the science is not yet clear
that those who are vaccinated will no
longer be contagious
so if you could still pass on the virus
even after getting vaccinated
that might make a vaccine passport less
useful
the data is looking pretty good towards
direction that vaccines probably
do protect against a reduction in
transmission
the extent to which they do that we
it's an evolving scientific
study also the science is still
unsettled as to
how long each vaccine works boosters
might be required
at different intervals for different
vaccines and that issue goes to the
difficulty of
how frequently someone would need a
vaccine passport renewed
and then there's a uniquely canadian
problem provincial governments are the
ones who hold detailed vaccination data
so
ottawa would need to negotiate access to
include it on a federal
travel document government officials say
there's also some privacy and ethical
concerns with
vaccine passports still energy sources
say there are solutions to all of these
problems
and they like to see ottawa and the
provinces get to work on them now
for the day whenever it may come that
canadians are ready to welcome back
foreign tourists
and even pack their bags themselves
david aiken global news
ottawa the copa 19 crisis in india is
getting even more
dire and officials say it will continue
to peak over the next two weeks
for the first time new cases of the
virus have topped
four hundred thousand in just the last
24 hours
more than 3 500 people have died from
the virus
pushing india's pandemic death toll to
close to 212
000. the situation has prompted the u.s
to join a long list of countries
imposing restrictions on travel from
india a move that will close a loophole
for canadians
hoping to travel home through the u.s
and a warning that some of our viewers
may find images in this story disturbing
day after day agonizing scenes from
india as the country struggles to get a
grip on its coven 19 crisis
the world is taking note fearful
infections will spread beyond india's
borders
america has joined canada and other
countries and announcing a new travel
ban on non-us citizens coming from india
already one of the copa 19 variants that
originated in india
has been discovered in michigan there's
going to be a travel restriction
starting on tuesday on the advice of the
centers for disease control
are covid 19 experts medical experts
our national security advisors the u.s
state department has also issued a
travel advisory against going to india
but some people are still traveling
there reluctantly i have to travel
or due to some family emergency but due
to the pandemic i'm little scary
as india's healthcare centers reach
their breaking point the u.s is sending
aid
two of these military planes left travis
air force base in california
carrying over 100 million dollars in
medical supplies
including oxygen n95 mass and rapid
cover 19 tests
the right thing i see right now is
thousands and thousands
of people that need help no more the aid
can arrive quickly enough as doctors
have no choice but to turn away the
critically ill
i get maybe around 50 calls every day
somebody's asking for beds somebody's
asking for cylinders somebody's asking
for drugs
we don't have anything adding to the
misery a fire in a coca-19
hospital ward in western india early
saturday that left at least 18 people
dead
this pandemic is the worst we have ever
seen till now
and these two weeks are going to be a
hell for us india has opened mass
vaccination sites to all adults
but some centers have already run out of
shots
as the death toll mounts this
gravedigger says they have run out of
room for all of the bodies
crematoriums are also running out of
wood so trees and city parks are being
cut down
and bodies are burned wherever there is
space
jennifer johnson global news washington
there could be a legal fight over
australia's unprecedented travel ban
that prevents its own residents from
returning
from india as of monday it will be
temporarily
illegal for australians who've been in
india to enter their own country
those who defied the order could face
fines of up to 63 thousand dollars
five years in jail or both direct
flights from india have already been
halted but the concern is over
australians traveling
via a third country we've also got to
protect australians
and the situation in india is dire and
insurance
very serious and we need to take and act
on the medical advice that is provided
to us
that's what we did at the start of the
pandemic that's what we're doing
right through this pending the move
leaves more than 9 000 australians
stranded in india the uk
sanctioned a rave as part of a pilot
project to see
how many more venues can be reopened
[Applause]
about 3 000 people packed a warehouse
for the two-day event
there was no social distancing and masks
were not required
but they had to test negative for kova
19 within 24 hours of arriving
those who attended will now be monitored
for symptoms and researchers will assess
the risks of transmission
the british government plans to lift its
lockdown entirely
in june coming up the legal mind
launching
another review into the canadian
military
for months global news has reported on
the allegations of sexual misconduct in
the military
defense minister harjit sajin has now
tapped retired supreme court justice
louise arbor to lead an independent
review
this is yet another review looking into
the canadian armed forces
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
davidson spoke with sudjan
on this week's edition of the west block
mercedes
robin this isn't the first time the
federal government is admitting it has
failed survivors of military sexual
misconduct
just six years ago former supreme court
justice marie deschamps
delivered her landmark report on this
very same issue
she laid out a clear path for the
government to address a problem that has
plagued the canadian forces
for decades but several of the reports
key recommendations were ignored
now both prime minister justin trudeau
and defence minister harjit sajin
are apologizing to survivors of sexual
misconduct we're sorry
we're sorry that um a process that
has failed you that did not give you the
comfort that you could
come forward and you know without the
fear of reprisal
something that we are absolutely
committed to fixing and we will
survivors tell me some are skeptical but
they are relieved to see the government
taking action there are still questions
though about whether
more should have been done in 2018.
that's when the military ombudsman at
the time told defense minister sajin of
an allegation of inappropriate behavior
by former chief of the defense staff
general jonathan vance
vance has denied all allegations he
acted inappropriately
the prime minister has said no one in
his office knew the complaint
was a quote metoo complaint but global
news has seen documents showing
bureaucrats were told the allegation
involved sexual harassment
and so i pushed the minister on what
exactly
he knew about that complaint were you
aware that it was sexual in nature or
had to do with conduct around women
we'll be honest that's that's something
that as i stated
um i didn't have much details um
on that um i wanted to my my priority
was to making sure that the former
ombudsman
was able to then take it immediately uh
and speak to the privy council
office about this so that the
appropriate action
could be taken also on the show this
week i'll speak with health minister
patty haidu on whether her government is
doing enough to protect canadians
from a crippling third wave of covid19
robin all right mercedes-stevenson in
ottawa thanks mercedes
you can see the interviews with defense
minister harjeet sudjan and health
minister patty haidu tomorrow on the
west block right here on global still
ahead a bombing leaves afghanistan in
anguish
at least 27 people were killed and more
than 100 others
injured in a suicide bombing in eastern
afghanistan
high school students are among the
casualties they were staying at a guest
house
preparing to take university entrance
exams when a truck packed with
explosives
was detonated outside the home the
seriously wounded were taken to
hospitals in the country's capital
kabul no group has claimed
responsibility yet
but the afghan government accuses the
taliban of carrying out the attack
afghanistan is bracing for more violence
as the u.s begins withdrawing its troops
from the country
about 3 500 american soldiers are still
there
president joe biden says it is time to
put an end
to what has become known as the forever
war today was the day all foreign
soldiers were to leave the country under
an agreement between the taliban
and the former trump administration the
u.s now says
all of its military personnel will be
out of the country by september
11th it has been three months since the
military seized power in myanmar
[Applause]
and today demonstrators returned to the
streets demanding the return of the
democratically elected leaders
protesters aren't giving up in the face
of a relentless crackdown
which includes internet blackouts at
least 759 people have died since the
february coup
according to an advocacy group more than
3 400 people have been imprisoned
the united nations warns that without a
collective international response
the general administration of the
country could risk
coming to a standstill a marathon a day
will keep
one bc woman busy all may up next the
cause
behind the kilometers
you get a love bite on your neck your
life's going down the toilet
academy award-winning actress olympia
dukakis has died
dukakis won an oscar for best supporting
actress in 1988
for her role in moonstruck starring
opposite cher
she captivated audiences with her
performances in steel magnolias
tales of the city and several canadian
productions
including the 2011 film cloud burst
olympia dukakis was 89. running a
marathon may be a once-in-a-lifetime
goal but a bc woman is making it her
daily mission this month over the next
30 days jana hempler plans to run
1266 kilometers
just thinking about it is exhausting but
this runner says she'll get her energy
from the cause behind her course
kylie stanton explains i'm not getting
any younger so it's either now or never
most people would choose never but janna
hempler
is not most people i'm going to attempt
to run
30 marathons in 30 days sort of this
marathon spree if you want to call it
that
hempler has plenty of training under her
belt back in 2013 she ran the length of
vancouver
island in 2015 she qualified and
conquered the boston marathon
and just last year she committed to
running 12 marathons
in as many days raising money along the
way
it just lifted my spirits you know to
see people donating and supporting and
it was just under 36 000 for the
victoria hospitals foundation
now with even more miles to cover she's
hoping to raise even more money
500 000 dollars in total that once again
will go directly to the victoria
hospitals foundation
providing priority equipment research
and education needs to the two biggest
hospitals on vancouver island
it's a time right now where i know that
everyone needs a little bit more
inspiration
especially our care teams when they know
someone like jana is doing something so
powerful and so stressful itself
it certainly helps you know the care
teams see this
and they know people are giving back to
the hospitals and they are so grateful
this pandemic has been a marathon in
itself
and while hempler knows the next 30 days
will be tough
she says they'll pale in comparison to
what frontline workers are experiencing
at least her run has a finish line our
healthcare heroes they need more support
than ever before
and so this is my way of honoring them
kylie stanton global news victoria
good for her and that is global national
for this saturday night
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
collins bay in kingston ontario
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
you